there's no room for egos there's no room
for personal preferences in a growing
business it's just a case of what is
best for the business when we other
business meetings we probably spend 90%
of the time not patting ourselves on the
back saying oh we didn't great oh wait
wow we spend 90% of the time saying how
terrible we are you know this is wrong
this is bad this could be improved this
is and after a meeting with Russell I'm
like man we've got so much room for
improvement and that's that's the way we
have a meeting so whilst we do celebrate
the successes we definitely are just
constantly trying to improve trying to
improve the systems try to improve the
business the product the service is the
way we invest our money the way we
encourage others to invest their money
we're just trying to get better and
better every day yeah and I've seen that
with my own eyes you definitely do
you're you're you're hard on yourselves
you're you are perfectionist you want to
provide the best possible service if you
want to be the best do only the best
which we do want to be you have to be
holding yourself as people say you're
too hard on yourself
but an athlete has to train hard and has
to be hard on themselves and I think in
business if you want to be the best you
just you have to be hard on yourself so
I don't get down about it
I don't think oh my gosh we're terrible
and then get down about it I'm actually
excited by it because of the room for
growth and speaking of growth how do you
go about recruiting people okay so I go
off gut feeling very much and I know
within within usually about a minute
whether I want to hire somebody or not
now I'm not saying I'm the best recruit
in the world I'm not saying all the way
I do it is the way to do it at all it
probably isn't but for me usually what
happens is I'll just be able to I don't
I don't really go through CVS I'm not
really interested in qualifications I'm
more interested in the attitude of the
person the energy of the person
than anything else I've employed people
that if I degrees in stuff like and
they're just they've just been terrible
at it you can train anyone to do
anything pretty much within reason of
course if they can if you can take it on
like a full-time accountant they'll need
to be qualified but if you're taking on
someone who's going to be in customer
service or media some of the guys some
of the videographers they're kind of
pretty much self-taught and I'm not
poopoo in the qualifications and stuff
that's all but to me that's definitely
second right if you want the company to
grow up our people have to grow and what
the Richard Branson says which I
absolutely love is train your staff so
well that they can leave but treat them
so well and I think that is for me I
love I want people to have that freedom
and have that choice and if they
definitely great but treat them so well
they don't want to but I love training I
love training and pound
I love seeing personal growth one of the
things that excites me more than
anything is seeing people get better
seeing people's seeing people get better
seeing their people skills get better
that confidence get better so many
people come just come come work for the
company and within a month I'm a
different person I'm so much more
confident I love life now I'm happier my
skills are better my top priorities that
people are doing a job or rather they
really enjoy if I sense that someone's
not happy doing what they're doing it
really bothers me
I just cannot and part of why teaching
my training business is to become
financially free to be able to you know
not have to do a job but I feel like I
want my team and my staff to be there
not because they have to be there and
because they want to be there that that
for me is the most important thing
that's not 100 percent and just because
I mean I work I come to the office I
work but I'm doing it from a position of
abundance because I want to it's a
mission I enjoy it and I want everybody
to feel that and I think that they
mostly do I think it's really important
that people feel valued and that people
feel appreciated so I do and sometimes
people might even feel uncomfortable
because I may be overly do it because
I'm just so
bubbling up with love and appreciation
for the guys it's another one oh my gosh
you know you're so awesome I really
appreciate you coming and so first
people might even be like well what the
heck but that is a real core value of
mine is recognition
[Music]